welcome back to our mini-series on the
what-if tool I'm Sarah a developer
advocate on cloudy high platform in the
last video James and I showed you how to
initialize the what-if tool how to run
it on various platforms and give an
overview of each of the three tabs today
we'll be diving into the data point
editor tab using the same model as the
last video which predicts whether or not
a house is worth more than 160,000 let's
get started when you initialize the
what-if tool you're brought right into
the data point out of your tab this
plots all of our test data along with
the models prediction for each data
point for the data points towards the
top our models have pretty high
confidence that the house is worth
$160,000 for the data points towards the
bottom it has high confidence of the
house is worth less than $160,000 our
model is less confident on the data
points towards the middle let's see what
happens when we click on an individual
data point here we can see all the
future values for this data point we can
also change any of the values to see how
this affects our models prediction looks
like doing this change the models
prediction significantly which you can
see here the next capability will look
at is partial dependence plots with the
data points selected we can see how
different features contributed to the
models prediction for this data point or
for all the data points in our data set
these are calculated by having the model
predict using the selected data point
while changing the value of only one
feature at a time and plotting it
results the dot in this graph is the
data point we've selected and the line
indicates the effect this feature has on
our model for example it looks like the
later house was built the more likely it
is to be priced higher houses with
unfinished garages are like the new
priced lower buyer model and houses with
a fireplace are likely to be priced
higher there's even more you can do with
the data point editor if we go back and
select a data point and click show
nearest counterfactual we can see the
data point that had features most
similar to the initial one we've
selected but with the opposite
prediction in the editor panel on the
left the what-if tool highlights the
difference between these two data points
in green and bold so we can see what
might have caused the op
prediction we can also make all sorts of
custom visualizations of her data points
making use of any of the features of the
data points or the model results here
we've created a histogram showing the
distribution of houses by square feet
with the points colored by the models
predictions as you can see on average
larger houses tend to be more often
classified as over 160,000 by our model
we can also use the same data point
similarity used for showing the nearest
counterfactual as a measure for custom
charts here we've selected a data point
we're interested in and organized all
data points along the x-axis by their
similarity to this selected one this way
we can easily explore how the model
forms on the set of data points that are
most similar to the one we're interested
in as you can see there's a lot of tools
you can use for inspecting your model
just within the data point editor in the
next video we'll be diving into the
performance and fairness tab for more
info on what we've covered here take a
look at the links in the video
description thanks for watching
[Music]